I'm here this morning with John George
of FTTH Council America's John your part
of the world is really taking off in
fiber and why why is it happening now
well what we've seen over the last 10 to
12 years in the Americas is a very
significant growth in fiber to the home
we've gone from twenty or thirty
thousand homes past to now we have over
32 million homes passed and about 14
million connected in the Americas and
that growth is really accelerated in the
last two years and and the reason is
we're seeing a lot of interest in the
higher speed applications people see
value in that and we're seeing more
building a fiber to the home networks to
meet those demands what sort of
applications give me a few examples I
guess a lot of its around movies being
in America isn't it well video is the
big driver of the bandwidth in the
Americas things like Netflix for example
Netflix is using a lot of Internet
bandwidth it's become very popular so
that people can view entertainment on
their own schedules and that's creating
a lot of demand for dedicated video
streams over the whole network to the
home and Netflix is now and also YouTube
and other applications they are
increasing the quality of the video from
standard high definition to 4k TV and
that will increase the bandwidth
requirements significantly 25 megabits
per second per video stream well so you
can imagine four of those video streams
running in a household like mine were my
children my wife they're all on netflix
simultaneously watching their own thing
will require 100 megabits of steady
internet capability and that will be the
kind of application that will see
filling these gigabit pipes that are
being built with fibre to the home in
the Americas now I know you also cover
Canada and Mexico how are things going
there we're seeing growth in both of
those countries as well for the same
reasons and we're also seeing a lot of
competition between the cable TV
operators the MSO
that are increasing their data rates and
speeds and offerings and so the
traditional telcos and even some new
entrants like Google who announced a
gigabit service for seventy dollars and
they're building a month and they're
building now in planning to build in
nine major metro areas 34 cities within
those areas we've had AT&T announcing
their plane to build up to 120 cities
with fiber to the home CenturyLink and
many smaller providers small cities
smaller telephone companies throughout
the country are beginning to build more
and more hundreds of them are building
fiber to the home so we see that
accelerating in the future if it sounds
tremendous market to be and I mean
what's next can you keep up with this
demand we can keep up with the demand
the industry is doing that and we see a
bright future ahead we still have about
eighty percent 75 to 80 percent of the
homes to cover in the Americas in North
America but we think that is going to
continue to grow and we'll cover those
in the coming years and new applications
that we haven't maybe even envision yet
will be developed to take advantage of
the bandwidth in reach to gigabit and
even believe it or not the first 10
gigabit fiber to the home service was
announced in the US just after Christmas
this past year so gigabit isn't even the
endgame for fiber to the home it can
reach 10 gigabit speeds in the future as
well John thanks very much for talking
to us you're very welcome thank you
tremendous insight there I think it was
a Canadian band that had the song you
ain't seen nothing yet maybe that
applies to this market to